[Music]
hey everyone welcome to the fifth
installment of Harry Potter theory in
this video I'm going to be discussing
the academic origins of a character we
all know and love Albus Dumbledore being
such a prominent and powerful figure in
Harry Potter Elvis is speculated to be
one of the most if not the most powerful
wizard in the Harry Potter universe this
made me wonder where did he get all of
his power how does he know so much
who taught Dumbledore Albus Dumbledore
was born in late August 1881 in a town
called mould on the world a mainly
Wizarding town in the UK in the autumn
of 1892 at the age of 11
Albus began attending Hogwarts when he
first started attending Hogwarts he had
a bit of a hard time this stemmed from
stigma surrounding his father Percival
who was sent to Azkaban for attacking
three muggle children Percival's actions
were in response to muggle children in
his home town attacking his daughter
analysis sister Ariana people were under
the impression that the Dumbledore
family hated muggles
Albus included this made his formative
year at Hogwarts fairly difficult it is
unclear who the headmaster was when
Albus attending Hogwarts though through
the process of elimination we can
determine that it was either Phineas
Nigella's plan or you Praxian mole
Phineas was born in 1847 and died in
1925 which to me makes him the more
likely choice as headmaster during the
time that Albus was a student Phineas
was a member of Slytherin house and
later became the school's least popular
headmaster he was also the
great-great-grandfather of Sirius Black
the third Phineas was difficult to get
along with and was known to butt heads
with Dumbledore his portrait would later
be hung in both the Headmaster's office
as well as at number 12 Grimmauld place
Albus was sorted into Gryffindor House
and on his first day at Hogwarts he
befriended a fierce Doge a pureblood
wizard with the
to become a member of the order of the
Phoenix despite rumors at albers hated
muggles he still made many friends who
saw him for who really was
these friends included Nicholas Flamel
Bathilda Bagshot and Griselda Marsh
banks in Albus seventh year at Hogwarts
he took his newts otherwise known as
nicely exhausting Wizarding tests for
both charms and Transfiguration newts
are tests at seventh year witches and
wizards take to prepare themselves for
careers after graduation a wizard can
only take the newt exams after
completing all of their owls or ordinary
Wizarding level exams and receiving a
score of exceeds expectations how you do
on your news will dictate what sort of
career path you follow in the Wizarding
World Alba stood exceptionally well on
his newts and Griselda Marchbanks
a professor working for the Wizarding
examinations authority remarked that
Elvis was able to do things with the
wand that she had never seen before
Elvis went on to win the Barnabas
Finkley Prize for exceptional spell
casting an award presented for show
casting excellent spell casting
techniques he also went on to win other
Wizarding accolades such as a gold medal
for groundbreaking contributions to the
International alchemical conference
Albus was as exemplary a student as one
could be and was clearly a shining pupil
with remarkable capabilities and an
uncanny ability to learn elvis graduated
from Hogwarts in June 1899 and returned
to his home of Godrich hollow to be with
his family after the death of his mother
Kendra Dumbledore Elvis being the eldest
sibling knew that he would have to take
care of his younger siblings
particularly Ariana who had problems
controlling her magical abilities it was
during this time that Albus became
friends with Gellert Grindelwald a young
man who had moved to his small village
to live with his aunt Matilda
Bagshot it was a family friend of the
Dumbledore's in Grindelwald great-aunt
immediately recognizing each other's
magical prowess and amazing magical
capabilities the two boys hit it off
immediately though it is not directly
stated I'm sure that the friendship
between Dumbledore and Grindelwald and
oddly resulted in increasingly powerful
magical abilities for both boys as they
were able to challenge each other's
abilities on a consistent basis before
befriended Grindelwald
Albus always out shown every other witch
and wizard who he interacted with he was
already unmatched in magical ability at
such a young age Grindelwald great-aunt
Matilda Bagshot was a gifted magical
historian and the author of a history of
magic which she was used to teach
students at Hogwarts from this we can
assume the powerful magic was clearly in
Grindelwald bloodline and as a result he
became a very powerful wizard at a young
age just like Dumbledore the coexistence
of the two young and powerful wizards
meant that they were challenged by
another for the first time resulting in
even greater power for the both don't
were those professors at Hogwarts are
never explicitly stated as there was not
much information on the school during
that time period all we know is a
Dumbledore did exceptionally well in
school and breeze through it without
much difficulty for this reason it is my
beliefs source of Albus power not come
so much through formal education but
moreso through his own inherent magical
prowess and curiosity additionally I
believed a great portion of his power
came after graduating from Hogwarts
after spending time with the nearly
equally powerful Grindelwald to sum it
up I think the Dumbledore's power can be
attributed to the following three
factors number one inherent knack for
magic stemming from a powerful bloodline
number two eagerness to learn and number
three time spent with Gellert
Grindelwald what do you guys think how
do you think Dumbledore became so
powerful did I miss something if I did
please let me know down in the comments
below with that I bid you farewell and
remember help will always be given at
Hogwarts to those who ask for
[Music]
you